he loved loves music and singing he
doesn't known as it should a lot of
people have their own opinion of what he
is I have always said she's got some
beagle in her maybe some type of pitbull
I know he's mostly terrier I think he
she's probably a dachshund mix maybe a
hound or something in there they said
that he's a Schnauzer cuz he has a beard
there could be terrier in there I
wouldn't be surprised all right obtain
cheek cells tick on its good boy okay
it's Dale so just be it Oh
twisted boobie what is this mechana
there we go buddy
yeah
Chihuahua miniature poodle cocker
spaniel what congratulations
he's American staff he's like hey fellas
Chihuahua American Staffordshire Terrier
and cocker spaniel
that is the weirdest combination you
don't look like any of you know how
crazy Oh Jim that explains so much so
one of her parents was Chihuahua
Staffordshire Terrier and the other one
was Chihuahua cocker spaniel Nick
unknown third great mix and there's no
dachshund in her at all no so he's
all-american staff like his parents and
it's animal inkblot on his resume
seriously that is very cool black dogs
aren't usually adopted but um he was
really cute I loved him and I wanted him
so I just got and I love him like that's
my best friend someone was just like
found the song on the street who wants
to take it yeah and then we were like oh
well take her we had talked about a lot
of the discrimination against pit bulls
you know we want you to go buy a dogs or
even like look for a pure Patrol it was
more just about rescuing and more just
about the dog's personality I don't
think a breed of a dog would ever make
or break an adoption it doesn't matter
what breed it is it's just love